[Music]
hello and welcome to
how the light gets in and to our session
on beyond
material now the topic for this morning
is of course materialism and beyond
is the world made of just one kind of
stuff
physical stuff that's been a popular
view
in the sciences for perhaps over 100
years although
more recently in science we have
abandoned
simple views of what the material is in
favor of talk
of fields and energy and people have
increasingly appealed to mathematics and
information
as the basic building blocks so
is materialism still going to do the
work we hope it's going to do
in providing us with an account of or
basis for
descriptions of reality after all it has
problems
making room for and providing
explanations of consciousness
so should we embrace other kinds
of perhaps immaterial dimensions to
reality
and if we do so will they help us with
our explanation
will they put us in a position to see a
better account
of many of the other things that we are
want to take
into our story about the full and
exhaustive furniture of reality
or are they always going to leave us
feeling that
there must be some underlying
physicalist or materialist
explanation of what reality consists of
with me to discuss these i've got a
panel of
sparkling speakers we have bernardo
castro now bernardo is computer
scientist he's been a
cern collaborator uh with with the
physics there
a philosopher as well and a denier of
material reality
bernardo is perhaps one of the most
prominent defenders now of
metaphysical idealism
we also have nancy cartwright so nancy
cartwright is a professor of philosophy
at the university of california san
diego as well as durham university
and nancy identifies herself as part of
the
stanford school of philosophy who argue
against to unified a view of science and
place greater emphasis on understanding
the practice of science over abstract
theorizing
finally we've got peter atkins who's an
outspoken
atheist i'm told but also a chemist and
an author of popular works of science
such as
atkins molecules so speakers
thanks for joining me and joining all of
us here online
i'm going to invite all of our speakers
now to take three minutes to set out
their stall
and to address the question does
anything
non-physical exist so
can we start with you bernardo
it i think it largely depends on what we
really mean by
the physical if by the physical we mean
this world
of perceptions around us the scholars
shapes
phenomena and objects that we see around
us
to deny this is just silly so i don't
deny
the perceptual world that physics
studies models and predicts
denying any of that is just silly but we
in our culture have taken a step further
we say that this world at its
fundamental basis
is not made of qualities the qualities
of perception of colors
melodies and flavors none of that
underlying this world there is a
material world or a physical world that
is fundamentally outside
independent and beyond experience
and that i think is a mistake and i'll
tell you why i think the way this
happened was that um
we start from qualities our experiences
and at some point we figured out that
with quantities we could describe the
relative differences between qualities
in a very handy way for instance
it feels different to lift a heavy rock
or to lift a feather
and we could encode that difference with
numbers
such as mass and weight handy
abstractions that allow us to describe
this world of quality or the difference
between blue and red
which we can describe as a delta in
frequency
and this was all very handy and then the
next thing we realize is that we all
inhabit the same world at least largely
the same that's also undeniable
there is something out there there is
some context out there where we are all
immersed and that's why our experience
of the world is so mutually consistent
and then we thought well guess what if
this world out there is outside our
individual minds
it must be outside mind itself now this
is bad logic but i think that's what
happened
and then we asked so what is there
beyond mentation
oh we have these handy quantities here
these handy numbers
that we've been using to describe
qualities maybe
they exist in and of themselves they
have a standalone existence
and there we went we replaced the
concreteness of the world
for a abstraction that we sort of
reified as having its own existence we
replaced the world by a description of
the world
and now we try to reduce the world of
qualities
to a world of pure abstract quantities
that by definition exclude our qualities
and and then we are surprised with the
heart problem of consciousness which is
just an artifact of bad thought
in my view we've taken a very wrong very
bad and examined step early on we've
become invested in it
and now we are paying the price for it
and we talk about well one day we will
solve the heart problem of course not
it's just an artifact of
of bad thinking so do i think there is a
world beyond the physical well
beyond the physical defined as that
which is not
qualitative and experiential i would say
sure
because that thing is just an
abstraction of mind it doesn't really
exist it's just a conceptual narrative
we tell ourselves
there is something beyond but that
beyond is the concrete
world of experience we do not
need to explain objective reality by
getting out of mind
we just need to get out of individual
minds
i think the world that is really out
there is a world of
transpersonal mental states nothing
maybe not intelligence not deliberate
doesn't have a plan i'm not talking
about these things
i'm talking about raw transpersonal
states which modulate our inner world
of perception and give rise to this
world of qualities around us
good thank you so um you see the problem
of
how we accommodate consciousness in the
world as as the problem of having
excluded qualities and so you start with
with the qualities
right there center stage and then you're
going to have to reconstruct bits of the
world from these trans
personal uh intersecting or overlapping
consciousnesses
okay that's that's that's one way to do
it so let's hold that thought and then
let's uh we'll come back to it i'm sure
let's go to nancy now uh is there more
than
physical things that we have to uh
concede in our ontology
oh barry i think the question doesn't
make sense
okay or i've heard i've never seen a
really good way to make sense of it
um most of the it's often put in terms
of the physical or the material and
most of the both materialists and
anti-materialists i know
are happy to lump under the term
material
all sorts of things that are obviously
not material
many of which you said at the very
beginning
that we study some of them we study in
modern physics
like forces fields energy
space-time curvature um so i worry
that the term tends to get used or it
often is used
as a way of claiming the metaphysical
high ground
without the effort of honest toil the
argument tends to go
sometimes a very simple argument look
here
a we all know that only the material
exists
b what you're talking about isn't
material
so c what you're talking about doesn't
exist
now in order for that argument to work
we have to have three things one is we
need a really good
characterization of what's meant in it
by the material
similarly if we want to say there's
nothing material right we need a really
good characterization of what we mean by
that
second we need a really good argument
that
what um all all that exists
is material or immaterial
and in the very way that we've
characterized the concept
and then three we need a really good
argument that what the opposition likes
isn't material in that very
same sense that we've characterized it
and i've actually never seen
um a good case where all three of these
came properly together
one way to try and give more content to
the
um that some people have tried to give
more content to the idea the physical or
the material
is really to focus on the idea physical
and
say that well what we're really talking
about is what
physics studies well now even if we
were uh just to look at reality through
the lens of modern science there are
hundreds of sciences
beyond physics and hundreds of thousands
of kinds of things
that these sciences take seriously as
working parts of the world
from neuron gates and dna strings to
civil war um sexual harassment
uh implicit bias or even epistemic
injustice
um and um
or so are some of these material
and some not and if some of them are not
what's wrong with them or if all of them
are what's wrong with that i mean what
what's the difference here and what's
wrong with it as far as i can see
there's no reason to believe
that these thousands of different kinds
of things
divide neatly into two categories
the physical the non-physical or
that they where the two categories have
any real content
or alternatively to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas